hallo ich wünsche mir das intro zurück
noch im auto waschen sich wieder beim
duschen gefilmt hey leute was genau war
jetzt willkommen bei einem neuen video
ja leute ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut
wir haben wunderschönes wetter draußen
die sonne strahlt in mein zimmer ja
darum geht es übrigens gar nicht also
schon und natürlich das wetter ist auch
immer gut wenn es schön ist dann wird
das video umso schöner dass euch mal
kurz erklären was ich vorhabe ja leute
ich würde euch kurz mal erklären was ich
heute vor habe ihr habt wahrscheinlich
immerhin schon gelesen whatsapp smileys
bestimmen einen tag mein leben jetzt
denkt euch so hell wie ist das denn
gemeint also war das sind ja auf youtube
diese videos ins team haben bestimmt
einen tag mein leben total in
ich hab das ja auch schon gemacht war
auch echt witzig also spaß gemacht nur
irgendwie wenn das jeder macht und man
andauernd bios vorgeschlagen bekommen
münster gar schon einen tag mein leben
das ist ja dann irgendwann langweilig
und auch immer das gleiche deswegen hab
ich mir jetzt gedacht hey was kann man
noch machen und bin auf die geniale idee
gekommen
whatsapp suisse bestimmen einen tag mein
leben das heißt eure aufgabe ist jetzt
schon mal 12 % mileys in einer
chronologisch sinnvollen reihenfolge in
die kommentare zu schreiben
für einen nächsten part wenn ich habe
mir heute morgen selbst für mich
persönlich 12 smileys hintereinander
geschrieben die blend stürmer kurz ein
praktisch wie so ein zeitplan also wie
ich den tag heute gerne verbringen würde
ich habe es mir selber ausgesucht für
ein zweiter partner ihren also dran dann
suche ich mir einen kommentar von euch
aus ich weiß ich habe jetzt verstanden
haben worum es geht
ich hoffe es und ihr werdet es auf jeden
fall verstehen also zum beispiel wenn
jetzt einfach gesagt als meine pizza
kommt oder so dann geht's halt pizza
essen oder wenn ihr lachen der im audi
kommt muss ich halt irgendwie spaß haben
so versteht ihr was ich meine
weil ich finde dass könnte echt
interessant lustig werden wenn ihr die
idee cool findet noch knapp auf den
zweiten fahrt dann schreibt es auf jeden
fall in die kommentare und lasst den
fetten daumen nach oben jetzt schon mal
da wird mich sehr freuen
und ich würde sagen wir fangen an wir
haben noch früher der tag ist noch lang
und
alex ist gespannt das wetter ist echt
richtig gut und als ersten punkt auf
meiner liste über hatte ich glaube ich
eine sonne
deswegen gehen jetzt erst mal raus und
genießen bisschen das wetter und ich
muss auch mal was essen also letzte halo
ich wünsche mir das intro zurück warum
ja weil das ist das beste überhaupt
finde ich nicht und ich finde es so
schade dass mein sohn nicht den wiener
hose hat und das intro darin lässt
ok so echt blöd so nachdem jetzt gehört
habt das intro ist natürlich sehr sehr
schade dass nicht mehr drin ist sieht
sich jetzt hier im garten ist es auch
nicht und wir gehen es fußball guckt
mein bruder hat ein fußballspiel ich hab
dann schon ewig nicht mehr beim
fußballspielen zugeguckt glaube ich dass
die kamera aber hier
oder wir sehen also es wird noch was
gegessen und damit jetzt los wir sehen
uns gleich so und zwar centers hat als
zweiten punkt
diese war dieses ende ist der absolute
aber ich muss mich beeilen
zack da man schon der sonne so herzlich
willkommen zurück
irgendwie hat gerade angefangen richtig
zu regnen auf jeden fall fußball war
sehr gut haben leider verloren aber wir
haben als nächsten punkt nach smiley
danach muss ich das auto waschen nach
schnell hier weil ich die eigentlich in
meinem auto waschen und danach
vielleicht nach köln also deswegen habe
ich diesen big city energy rec gemacht
wo also um jetzt mit so ein bisschen
witz nach köln zu kommen brauche ich ja
so ein gute laune video irgend ein
lustiges youtube video vielleicht von
das passt sehr gut leute ich krieg hat
hier eine mail
mein ok ich hab dein mail ein dass es
ist nicht mal von mir dass videos auch
nicht von mir
was ist das für eine mail sowie hat mir
irgendwann tür geschrieben wie viel es
dein outfit wert reiche youtuber edition
video gesehen und mich gefragt wie alt
du bist du lac viele grüße dein hater 1
ja jetzt hast du super mail rausgesucht
da kann man auch gar nicht seinen ganzen
namen sehen sind froh dass ich das
zensiere ich denke nie wirklich manchmal
wie blöd sind einige menschen so das ist
ja meine geschäfts mail und ich krieg da
manchmal echt komische komische
nachrichten das für mich gehört sich
nicht
also leute aber jetzt darf das natürlich
noch das ist ganz klar ich war auch noch
gar nicht auf youtube unterwegs das
passiert ja eigentlich immer ziemlich
viel und hochgeladen hat heute schon
weiß ja das tue ich immer gerne max
planck mitarbeiter alles ansprechen
entweder er lässt es jetzt würde ihr
kind gehen
spring mit der seite alles sprechen
super so ich muss jetzt auf jeden fall
automation eigentlich würde reichen wenn
ich einmal draußen lang fahren würde
weil es regnet und dann geht es los nach
köln ich habe meine sachen nämlich auch
schon gepackt hier habe ich so einen
wäschekorb da sind echt viele klamotten
drin im koffer auch noch so ein paar
sachen und hier selber shampoo für meine
wundervolle habe und das hier ist meine
technik rucksack in sofia eurocity geht
immer eine menge rein
also das ist echt ein schock sein also
legen autowaschen und wenn uns beim
autowaschen und jetzt kommt sogar wieder
die sonne raus schaut euch das an der
himmel klart auf welt und jetzt schaut
mal wie krass das ist ohne filter und
wie krass ist es mit filter und wie
krass ist dass ich nicht schnipsen
können solche auf geht's für gutes
einscheiben langsam einfach ganz klar so
jetzt bin ich auf jeden fall gut
eingestimmt und sieht hinten gar nichts
mehr
und heute ich habe das auto wird wieder
blitzeblank ich war jetzt monatlich hier
also ich bin gespannt was gleich also
leute vor allem wenn man hier malen die
felgen schaut ist das wieder echt extrem
sauber irgendwann später habe ich gar
nicht getankt und jetzt geht es nach
köln endlich mal was heißt endlich weiß
genau drei tage oder so
sprit ist ganz schön teuer heute 13 41
44 pro liter
manche mich auch für 129 aber gut habe
ich voll getankt wir noch ein leckeres
getränk geholt und jetzt geht's los
metzger ich bin jetzt gerade hier
ja ich bin etwas davon
denn eigentlich schnell vorbei wenn es
nicht so voll ist war ja eigentlich
immer am liebsten irgendwie haben zum
andern ist fast gar nichts los
über den link
wer so die kamera was ich jetzt erstmal
wieder weglegen weil jetzt kommt
baustelle und hier ist es immer so dass
später so leute an komik hierher
das wetter ist ja eigentlich ganz gut
also manchmal ist die sonne da manchmal
nicht und ich sind auch willkommen
gangster
also leute was geht wir haben schon fünf
nach elf jetzt also ziemlich spät abends
und fluss morgen relativ früh raus
deswegen wollte ich auch nicht allzu
spät schlafen gehen
als letzten punkt auf meiner liste habe
ich ja den schlaf
was sagst du dann zu meiner idee wenn es
nicht gut
du hast zahnschmerzen sind unglaublich
er hat mich von 1 meter 50 und kann
jutta gemessen
und da haben liga total stolz von meiner
idee erzählt was ich da gerade macht und
er fand es lustig und ich gar nicht
verstehe ja dass wir noch auf jeden fall
ist der nächste der bürger mode und
kommt mir eigentlich ziemlich recht und
ich würde sagen wir mal gucken ob wir
noch irgendwo was leckeres zu essen
finden wegenetz auf jeden fall in den
burger essen so spät abends aber ich bin
eben ein bisschen hinterher mit meinen
mahlzeiten deswegen ist es kein problem
was tun im auge haben
der laptop zerstören also leute
letztlich geschlossen worden sind hatte
ich kann ja die zeigen soll
die sandwich im audi fußball im audiamo
die auto waschen sich jeder beim duschen
gefilmt das steht für autowaschen war
nacht und eine banane essen
ich bin der einzige der die banane ist
schaut man das auto das hier gewinnt
wieder richtig sauber aus
[Musik]
junge leute wir sind die einzigen hier
mac ist keiner mehr da
außer der mitarbeiter ist soweit wieder
back in unserem zuhause drin auf jeden
fall haben wir echt schon relativ spät
und ich wollte jetzt eigentlich gerne
schlafen gehen deswegen würde ich sagen
werde ich den blog ganz spontan hier im
auch zu wie gesagt gebt noch nach oben
bei den noten folge war kommentiert ganz
viele hat siebenmal nicht noch ein paar
und juli spielt jetzt noch seinen ganzen
will und dann kann ausschlafen gehen